MAN (VOICEOVER): Susie's here.
We've been building a wicked
Corvette for her, man.
A beautiful C4 car.
Susie, how you doing?
I'm doing wonderful,
I'm excited.
Feeling good?
She's a cool lady.
The car is amazing.
I hope she digs it, man.
Come on baby, bring
out that Vette.
And yes, it's
really the same car.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's gorgeous.
It's-- more beautiful
than I imagined it.
She's all yours.
MAN (VOICEOVER): We wanted to
update Susie's beloved Vette.
But we kept all that
head-turning 80s charm.
The car is still fast as
it was back in the day.
So we concentrated on her looks.
Now we did a few things
like replace hoses and belts
and tuned it up, added a
beautiful Borla exhaust setup.
But that's about it.
And that banana
yellow paint might
have been hot back in 1987.
But for the new millennium
we turn Susie's Vette
into a tangerine dream.
Ryan added black accents
in all the right places
to make her look sleek,
fast, and totally unique.
New wheels and tires and a
fully customized interior
complete this
totally cool, fully
updated 80s street machine.
MAN: Some of the obvious stuff
that we did, we completely
changed the rear end.
The whole back
bumper of the car,
we wanted to update it to
the ZR1 styled rear bumper.
It's just a really pretty
back end look to it.
And Ghetto Bob here, I'm going
to give some monster kudos.
All right.
The rear wing on this car
was something that you loved.
But it never was
really very correct
in its original installation.
- Right.
That's the same old wing,
it's just been modified.
Right.
It's flatter, and it's cut
out for the [inaudible] that
you used to hit all the time.
So it's how it should have
been built the first time.
Exactly.
That's how it should it
come first the first way.
RYAN: Matches the body
lines much better.
SHANNON: Right.
SUSIE: I love that black.
That's a surprise.
RYAN: Yep.
SHANNON: Yeah.
SUSIE: That is-- I
didn't even imagine that.
Black and orange
go together so well.
SUSIE: So well.
MAN: Yes they do.
RYAN: Especially
with that much glass
all the way around
the top of the car.
SUSIE: Yes.
RYAN: There's so many oranges
that have been overdone.
And this orange is
usually forgotten.
Because most people
don't apply it right.
They apply it over
the wrong color
and it just comes out kind
of dingy and almost brown.
This one, we applied it
over the correct color.
It came out bright and vibrant.
It's almost like a butterscotch.
It really accentuates
all the body lines.
And with all the glass, the huge
glass hatch top, even the glass
roof, and all the
windows around it,
there was so much
black already there.
SUSIE: Right.
- I just took advantage of that.
Brought the black across the
hood and across the back.
And it lowers the
whole top of the car.
It just squishes it even more.
Oh, it looks even
faster than it was before.
MAN: Exactly.
We added a whole
new set of wheels.
You had some old school
gold wheels on it.
SUSIE: Oh, gold wheels.
RYAN: Which were very
proper back in the day.
SUSIE: In the-- yes.
But we took it
into a modern car.
So we added these
insanely gorgeous
gloss black wheels on it.
We went with a Cooper
tire RS3 set up on it.
They're like a summertime tie.
They're really sticky.
So for a car like this,
it'll handle phenomenal.
And trust me, these
guys have been building
tires for 100 plus years.
They're absolutely phenomenal.
I love their product.
So car sticks to the
ground like amazing.
- Yeah.
- And you got to see the inside.
Oh!
You're not going to
believe what happened inside.
- I know, I know.
- Inside got even crazier.
[gasps]
How does that feel in there?
Like I'm never
getting out of it.
How do you like that
dark, dark wood in there?
I love it.
MAN: It's beautiful.
SUSIE: Beautiful.
It's classy.
RYAN: It's not real wood.
So it's not going to fall
apart and delaminate over time.
SUSIE: It's beautiful.
MAN: This is the
first C4 we've done.
And when it came
in, it was a lot
of sitting around
staring at it, wondering
what are we going to do.
And this car has now made a
serious believer out of us.
And I personally love it.
This car is beautiful.
It's not for sale.
MAN: Come on, man!
I love her more than
the day I got it in 1988.
Amen.
I thought it was
beautiful then.
MAN: It was.
SUSIE: This is more beautiful.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome, darling.
Man, I got to
tell you, there's
nothing like seeing a lady
in love with her Corvette.
She is so happy, man.
Susie and Mike, these two
been married for 50 years.
Most cars don't
even last that long.
So I'm so happy that
we get to put a dot
on the I in this love story.
Starring Susie, Mike, and
a little orange Corvette.
If you guys are happy, let's
go do a little paperwork
and get you on your
way to Palm Springs.
So you can scare Mike
on that back road.